[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality host of the
fine print one of the ramsey networks uh
best listened to podcasts is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
relationships mental health we answer
your questions about jobs and careers we
answer your questions about your money
and your life and your marriage and your
parenting and sometimes we're right the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five two two five but we are this
we are definitely an expert on our
opinion so you got that
triple eight eight two five five two two
five thanks for joining us william is in
tampa to start this hour hi william how
are you
i'm great dave how are you guys better
than we deserve brother what's up
hey um well i am uh 42 years old and i
make about 48 nine hundred and i shall
be debt free by the end of this summer
woo-hoo i'm excited
um and i want to know um i know the
emergency fund you say is three to six
months worth of expenses but what about
uh checking and how much should i keep
in checking and my emergency fund my
like i said my income is around 48 000
and i just want to know how much i
should keep in both accounts once i'm
completely debt-free sure so william do
you have a stable
income uh yes sir i'm a teacher all
right good and are you married
uh no sir single okay
so if you're single uh you've got a
stable job but you can play within that
three to six if you've got a stable job
and you want to lean towards the three
that would be fine if you don't have a
lot going on there do you already have
that you said you're getting out of debt
so you still need to go work on this
emergency fund after that correct
correction yes okay so you once you have
that three to six months on the savings
side on the checking side you obviously
have to have enough to cover all of your
expenses in a monthly budget but i'd
also have a little buffer a little
foundation maybe 500 bucks where you go
all right 500 is basically zero that's
kind of your new baseline so that you're
not running into you know situation
where you're over drafting yeah we do
run a zero-based budget we don't run a
zero-based checking account
because that just life's too short okay
so you do want to keep a pad in there of
some kind
and yeah i'm with george i think three
months and if you just take your
paycheck for three times i know that's
not your expenses that's your income but
that's not gonna be that far off of your
expenses and that might end up to be
four or five months of
uh there but if you had three months of
your pay set aside that would be
probably in the four to five months of
expenses set aside once you're debt free
so
um you know somewhere in there
the point is to be ready for a rainy day
because it's gonna rain
dave you need to be positive i'm
positive it's going to rain you need to
get ready all of us have stuff happen
and the weird thing is that if you have
a big old emergency fund uh it turns an
emergency into an inconvenience you
start to have less emergencies it's
amazing my favorite george was a hundred
years ago it feels like now it was
probably 20 plus years ago i was
teaching a financial peace university
class this lady was sitting in there and
she said oh it's a glk fund
and i'm like what and she said my
grandmother raised me we always had a go
fund and i said what's the g.o.k fund
she said well i took care of anything
like the car broke we got the gok fun i
had to have braces one time it was a gok
fund and she said my granny always just
had the joke what is that
god only knows oh i love that it's a
great emergency yeah that's good i like
it so i'm going with that but the point
is is that most people walk around with
absolutely no money in one of the
wealthiest societies that the world has
ever known because we spend like you
most people spend like they're in
congress yeah i mean it's just they're
out of freaking control and they don't
have any money and so all we're teaching
you is a little bit of common sense here
carry an umbrella because it's spring
and it might rain
it won't cover the
catastrophes but it covers most of
life's emergencies and the weird thing
is when you're 100 debt free other than
your home and you have that emergency
fund baby step 3 done
you quit having emergencies yeah it
turns into an inconvenience and you go
well i can take better care of my stuff
i can buy higher quality stuff i can do
maintenance on my stuff and all of a
sudden you're not dealing with it yeah
when i started doing this i didn't even
know that part of it
because i hadn't experienced that part
of it but you're right as you build
wealth
your car is better and you don't wail
the tire blows to get new tires and you
don't wail the brakes squeak to get new
brakes and you know that kind of stuff
and you know
you're you're right you're not you know
everything's not a piece of junk in your
life
and so all of a sudden then crap doesn't
break as much and you're not waiting
till you need a root canal to get your
teeth looked at
that's a scary one well i don't know
about that one but
have you had a root canal ah
no okay good let's keep it that way and
you know what i still have my wisdom
teeth isn't that weird a lot of wisdom
that's weird i think i do too that's why
we're so smart that's it that's it you
and me what's the secret america we have
this cornered right here all right uh
terry's with us in new hampshire hey
terry what's up
hi dave hi george i'm so excited to talk
to you i'm a huge fan well we're honored
can we help you
thank you i've been listening to you for
three years and i'm out of debt except
for my home which i'll pay off in under
four years from now so thank you for all
your help with my finances
so much
so i've been a teacher for 22 years and
i'm thinking about retiring things are
getting just as you know probably i'm
just really muddy and confused
so um i have a choice to oh wait you're
like one of those teachers that wanted
to teach and stuff
yeah okay i wanted to teach kids yeah
you want to teach kids and they got
confused
yeah about teaching kids okay i'm with
you yes
so my pension right now would be 1800 a
month for life my district will also pay
me 1500 a month for five years and allow
me to keep my medical insurance so i'm
65.
i need to know whether to
take that 1800 a month or take the lump
sum which is
right now a hundred ten thousand dollars
and that's after 22 years of
contributing
so i know you always say to take the
lump sum but i use your calculator and
if i were to invest that 1800 a month i
would come out a lot better
so what do you think dave
you come out a lot better until you die
until i die exactly and when you die
they keep all the money in the pension
and when you pulled it out it's an
emergency in a mutual fund in your name
and your heirs will get that hundred and
ten thousand dollars now it doesn't die
with you
yes he did i don't think that 110 is
gonna produce twenty thousand dollars a
year that's a that's a pretty good
trade-off they've got that discounted
pretty heavily
uh so you're you're right i don't think
i don't think you're going to get 1800 a
month off of 110 000 invested that'd be
a 20 ready okay so
so i i think you're going to take a loss
on your monthly income if you take the
lump sum but the long term play is to
take the lump sum do you need the 1800 a
month to exist
no i wouldn't because i would be getting
a second
career so i could just invest it
i'd take the lump sum
then i would roll it and i'll roll it to
a traditional ira it will not produce
the same monthly
but believe me the
the pensions run they have actuarial
tables and they run the numbers out as
to you know how they're projecting your
death in these numbers
okay and they know they're coming out
ahead
uh
and so i'm always taking that lump sum
and almost always it works both ways
better off with the income and
upon death in this case it's only going
to be upon death but
but i'm still taking it and if you keep
it you get to have that for as a legacy
you know to your family that inherits
that ira or whatever it is versus the
pension you know you reach 65 you can do
a lot of stuff with it you can do it i
mean 59 and a half you can do a lot of
stuff with a lot of options yeah
this is the ramsey show
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you
america for joining us this is the
ramsey
delta just announced this headline just
announced a brilliant plan to take a
bite out of this 100 billion dollar
industry straight out of apple's
playbook analysts have said they expect
that this summer will be the biggest
travel season ever big deal for the
airlines which have struggled over the
past two years with the covet 19
pandemic millions if not billions of
people who have largely stayed close to
home during the pandemic are likely to
venture out to encourage those travelers
delta just announced a brilliant
strategy
this is uh from about delta's press
release by the way that they're into
humility and it's brilliant brilliant
it's brilliant remember those beer
commercials oh yeah
uh it's jumping on board with buy now
pay
later
bnpl
over the past years the buy now pay pay
later industry has exploded alongside
the surge in online shopping the idea is
that a shopper can spread out payments
usually over three to six months the buy
now pay now pay later uh representing a
hundred billion dollars in
2020 and uh delta wants a piece actually
i think it's appropriate george because
with delta you usually buy now and fly
later i love that that's perfect
delta is greek for we ain't really going
oh my goodness and um it's a it's
ridiculous and so now they're going to
go ahead and just get you get in the
finance business and you're financing
your airline ticket you did a whole
segment on the fine print on this buy
now pay later we do which is it's an old
it's an old thing with a digital twist
yeah i mean you remember layaway back in
the day but now no layaway didn't have
interest you had to actually pay to get
the product now you get it right now
instant gratification
we don't have the patience we want to
just microwave everything have it right
now and that's what this is you talk to
people they got really stuck in this
they're buying little items but a lot of
them yeah and it's like it's a thirty
dollar item and you got three payments
of 9.99 or something my god
i was just looking at the tweets today
of just people talking about these
companies and they're talking about it's
33 and i have the money but
i'm gonna do the after pay i'm gonna do
klarna i want to do it in seven dollar
payments for the next four months and
you can add more and more to that yeah
and well you you talk to people that
really got like credit card debt or
something they really got into a mess
with yeah lululemon that was we talked
to one girl who spent 10 grand with buy
now pay later on lululemon gear gotta
have it and so the mentality of this uh
what it says is i want it now and i
refuse to wait and save up and pay for
it when i can afford it and we're seeing
the klarna and after pay all these
companies they're bragging to retailers
saying hey if you use our product if you
use this service the customers will
spend 45 percent more well airlines have
been completely buttholes to their
customers over ma over max masks and
vaccines and now they they want to play
nice you know now they want to go yeah
yeah we're gonna you don't even have to
pay
it's like yeah we we know what you're up
to here boys and girls well they
literally say in the article you might
even spend more than you otherwise would
which is the biggest benefit to any
merchant that decides to let customers
pay over time even if you're not
collecting interest if you make more
sales for larger amounts that's a huge
win so you tell me who's winning here
the customers no it's the buy now pay
later companies it's delta not you see i
thought rooms there they went was the
only place that you did
you know
uh nothing down for 90. there's nothing
down for 90 days right no payments for
90 days zero interest for 90 days 90
days same as cash now we have your
freaking airline ticket
that's insane dave you're gonna love
this part it's a sign the world is is
truly coming to an end well for a lot of
reasons this is this [ __ ] so this is the
one that broke the camel's back right
here well no pun intended with a camel
sitting right here but here's the thing
dave it says in order to take advantage
of this new option you have to use one
of delta's co-branded american express
cards
you love that don't you oh yeah i love
for delta that might be the most
brilliant part of all
yeah their company's relationship with
american express is quite possibly the
most valuable part of its business
i've heard all i need to hear yeah let
me help you with this when corporate
america delta airlines
is so freaking stupid
that the only thing that they are
thinking about
when it comes to their customers
is how they can milk you like a dairy
cow then they have lost their way
they are supposed to serve the customer
not milk the customer
this is this is when corporate america
is serving i i know that the stockholder
is king and i know you've got to make
your profits for q1 and q2 to keep your
little
wall street people happy but if you
don't keep your customers happy
you go bye-bye and no one cries
so when delta goes bye-bye it's going to
be like some of these other people that
did nobody's going to be crying as a
matter of fact we may be doing a little
little ramsay dance in here oh i don't
have to invent that but it's not going
to be going to do the dance uh we don't
you can't see it cause it's not been
invented yet we'll film it when we come
up with it george you'll be the first to
see it thank you but i mean yeah my god
milk your customers this is a core value
of this company well they're getting a
lot of milk dave it says delta expects
this relationship to bring in as much as
seven billion dollars in revenue by next
year
seven billion
takes your breath and they're not even a
good airline no i mean this is tough
i mean it's just
when i see delta come through and and it
shows up on my email as a ticket i'm
just always going oh god
you know i mean how many people do you
do business with that when you see them
come across and you're getting ready to
interact with them you sigh and groan
you know that feeling and that's what
this is so and now it's even worse now
it's even worse so yeah guys you brought
this on yourselves and uh as long as you
keep screwing your customers we're going
to keep talking about you
and it ain't going to be nice
so we'll just keep it up and don't fall
for this stuff guys guys really pay for
this you can afford a plane ticket
sit your little butt at home if you
don't have the money to fly come on this
is serious
well i didn't i needed i need vacation
shut up stay at home
if you don't have the money stay at home
dave that hurts people's feelings i know
but i'm concerned about people's
feelings i've always been concerned
that's true feelings it's it's a big
thing with me
so no i want you to have a good life i
don't give a crap about your feelings i
want you to win i want you to
retire a baby steps millionaire i want
you to be able to leave an inheritance
to your children's children not delta's
children
that means i can't do my instagram
instagram post from cabo dave
well if i can't travel to combo i can't
do the instagram podcast
i said you couldn't travel unless you
couldn't afford it okay i'm riding an
air dave yeah that's an airline that'll
never say i might be posting from cabo
any minute it could happen at any moment
but i can freaking afford to get down
there and i'm not having to finance my
airline ticket even worse weight on your
your skyline miles from your accrued
credit card rewards to afford to go
somewhere that's an even worse plan
this is like putting three stupid things
together american airline miles pay now
four stupid things okay airline miles
buy now pay later american express and
flying delta these are four stupid
things
yeah it's like oh my gosh this is like a
lot of reasons to not do this
and i really don't see any reasons on
the plus side here um
because they're going to treat you like
cattle when you get on there and hit you
with a taser if you don't wear your mask
just to suit them
they charge you for breathing now too
that's an extra charge breathing yeah
yeah breathing well that that'll that'll
increase revenue yeah that breathing
things
that's popular leg room yeah carry-ons
you name it they'll get you
leg room yeah that's one you struggle
with that's true that's one of the many
benefits of being as small as i am
plenty of leg room i stretch out dave
you don't you don't have to have that
issue yeah that is a benefit it really
is thanks for for letting me see the
silver lining there well i mean that's
what you're here for well it saved you
some money george you let's try that
extra expensive seat
good times and i'm short i don't have
i'm not as short as you but i'm short
and i i don't have the legroom thing
either not an issue for me i have a
belly issue
sometimes that tray comes down it's a
problem yeah but um you don't have that
issue no so see everybody's got their
everything's everybody's got something
they got to carry thank you for that
reminder there you go all right we just
we took it full circle i don't know
where the circle ended but it's full i
hope this circle doesn't go unbroken
uh
oh my gosh
delta's not going to reach out for the
sponsorship now you know you don't think
they're grounded i don't think it's
going to be the ramsay show delta studio
from the delta studios it would be
hilarious but i don't see that in our
future i don't think that's happening i
don't think american express is signing
up either
then i guess i'll just have to i'll just
have to live with that yeah you'll be
all right this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Music]
well it's finally warming up in
tennessee if you guys want to stop by
our studios in our lobby we have a whole
visitor center here at ramsey you can
sit and watch as we do the show every
day it's kind of like watching ugly
paint dry but you can do it
and we have free coffee and the free
homemade cookies and uh whoever's on the
show comes out at the commercial breaks
and signs books and takes pictures and
whatever else and say hey we love seeing
you guys and if you're out and about
there's absolutely no charge we pay for
everything we want you to take them in
here and just enjoy yourself and see
what all is happening here the debt free
stage is in here where people do their
debt free screams in person sometimes
sometimes they call in uh but um you
kind of get to come in here and see all
the stuff and and uh
uh it's it's quite an experience it's
become a tourist destination
site here in nashville a little south of
nashville actually in franklin tennessee
beautiful franklin tennessee
so come out we would love to have you
anytime and now that the weather's
breaking up some of you are getting out
and about and
most everybody's open and moving around
now out there um we've been open and
moving around over here for a while but
but um so we're not we're not freaked
out but we still have people kind of
walking in looking like is there
something is is it okay you know it's
okay it's okay we'd love to have you and
uh so come on hold on am i the ugly
paint i'm just putting two and two
together here
i know i've been the ugly paint for 30
years okay i'm the pretty paint thing
you're you're the pretty wallpaper thank
you so there you go but it is fun i
always love no pretty paint but you're
pretty well packed well half the guests
here are going hey dave we're moving
here everyone's trying to get to
tennessee yeah yeah that's true and we
actually are you know we're we have a
little quiz you have to take before you
can come to the state and it involves
you learning to vote correctly because
we don't want you bringing your crap
over here and screwing up our wonderful
state so if you're leaving over there
because it sucks don't bring your vote
when you come okay unless you know how
we're going to teach you we have a
little remedial voting class so it's a
one question pop quiz yeah well it's
yeah it's just you know well i might
have a few on there about common sense
and stuff too because that's good we
need to know
around here we've been known to
believe in the first amendment the
second amendment and the third amendment
the fourth amendment we believe in all
the amendments yeah and the constitution
and stuff and so
yeah and you're liable to see that
around and it's shocking to you if
you're not from an area that you see
that kind of stuff so
uh those things pop up around here the
free speech thing and
might be uh
someone might be armed and it's just
it's a different world for some of you
so um
but we'd love to have you visit and if
you want to move here we'd love to have
you we're we are southern hospitality uh
but but yeah so you're right half the
people are like hey we're we're looking
at houses today yeah okay
that's we know we know and we live this
is the most expensive county in all of
tennessee where is this the 11th
wealthiest county in the nation wow this
county yeah i tipped the scales that was
me dave i'm sorry yeah it's um yeah well
i mean we
we knew you were here for something well
and it's all the country artists too
they're all around here
half of them yeah they're all around
here but that ain't that's not what it
was
so but anyway
some of them have some money yeah some
of them used to have some money the ones
that you're friends with yeah you've
taught them well well i don't know
john rich is doing all right
yeah it's the name but yeah
so
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five ryan is with us
in san antonio hey ryan how are you
hi dave and george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up i got a question
about an uh under performing mutual fund
in my 401k
uh
a little backstory about 12 months ago
define underperforming
uh
it's
out of the
all the mutual funds
options in my 401k the last 12 months
it's been
pretty much the worst performing mutual
fund and what
category is it what category of fund is
it uh
small cap so i guess does that translate
to yeah
aggressive it's a small cap yeah or yeah
yeah exactly 12 months ago
how does it compare to other small cap
funds out in the world
uh
worse off than most the other ones but i
i do see that the other ones are not
doing so great the festival month as
well i wasn't a passive aggressive
question because but that's how you
compare
you don't compare your small cap to your
growth and income and say oh i'm
ditching the small cap because the small
cap may be having a rough season it is
small companies who are more susceptible
to volatility in weird times like we're
in
and so it may have taken a hit i hadn't
even looked at mine i don't know but um
but but you don't compare you don't say
oh my small cap is under performing my
growth in income but if your small cap
is underperforming most all other small
caps or other small caps that you have
inside your options of your 401k then
yes you would jump off that horse does
that make sense
yeah it does and i guess my main
question was like how long would you
hold on to a
grossly underperforming mutual fund and
i feel like 12 months isn't that long
enough i'm not ready to no that's enough
12 months is enough if if it is if it's
underperforming if it's one of the in
the bottom percent of all small caps or
of uh you know are substantially off for
12 months i'm probably jumping
if you got another small cap to go to in
the 401 k but i want you in growth
growth and income aggressive growth
international
and the aggressive growth is a small cap
so you need to have something in that
category that you jump to
and but the trick is not to say
oh my mutual funds are down well the
stock market might be down oh my mutual
funds are down well that category of
stock of fun might be down
that doesn't mean we destroy the
diversification we still ride the horse
then but if uh but if all small caps are
up and yours is down well you got a
sucky fun jump out after over 12 months
i'd be out of it
that makes sense i appreciate your input
hey man thanks for the call
that's important because people
we want all four categories to do well
all the time and they almost never do
that's why you have four categories yeah
it's well balanced exactly if one is
going down chances are another one's
going up and we've seen international
has not been doing so hot for years now
but right when the other ones go down
international tends to
bump up and so we want that balance
there it kind of feels like you're at
the grocery store and you choose the
right line and you go oh that line's
going to be the fastest and you get in
you go oh my gosh this lady's using
coupons and a check this is going to
take four hours i should have gone on
the other line so you jump to the other
line so it's a little bit of that dance
you're feeling there where you can you
chose just never works and it doesn't
even work in the grocery store line no
you go from one to the other and it's
just and then that one's clocked and
then they got to do a price check i mean
oh my gosh you know it's like right
you're right so you just got to keep
track of it play through
play through and uh
you know the other one i do and i do all
of these except with the investments i
don't do with investments but you're
riding down the road and you you know
you see the traffic's backing up so you
pop up pop up the app right and say oh i
gotta get off
and as soon as you get off it starts
moving yeah
right as soon as you go i'm going to go
around the country road as soon as you
do that it starts moving you should have
just
sat there and played things no no not me
no i i have the patience of a flea
so no except when it comes to investing
when it comes to investing because my
intellect will overrule my little boy
emotions and i stick with it so which is
what i try to help you guys do every day
here
james is in dothan alabama hi james
welcome to the ramsay show
hey how you doing great man what's up
well i i'm calling to get advice i'm
trying to set my mother up uh
hopefully for the rest of her life she's
70 years old i'll give you the
one
in a nutshell she's seven years old
recently widowed
she's never managed her own affairs
she's never even balanced her own
checkbook
her income is going to be because it
just got cut her social security is
gonna be about 1600 a month
her current bills are 2200 a month
uh she has of which her bills are she's
got another three years to pay on a uh
bankruptcy at the tune of about 353
dollars a month
right
her assets are these she's got the uh
social security coming in but she has an
ira with 25 000 in it
and some insurance money uh from dad's
death
uh and i'm trying to set her up to the
last of the rest of her life and you
already see the gap between the income
and the uh and the bills
our major goals how much was how much
insurance money was there
uh 78 000. okay
does she want your help
well she needs it i know she needs it
i'll be honest oh she needed it 10 years
ago does she want it will she listen to
you
she doesn't really have a choice
yeah she does all right hold on we'll
come back and talk to you after this
break this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
we're talking with james in dothan
alabama his father just passed away left
his mom 78 grand she's got 25 grand on
an ira
they're in a chapter 13 bankruptcy she's
70 years old she has no assets other
than that
um has a little bit of income from
social security but it's not enough to
pay her bills and he said she's got to
have to change some things and that's
where we were talking is that a fair
summary of what you told us so far sir
yes sir that's a fair summary and answer
your question from before yes she is
willing to accept my help okay that's
good that's good because that makes a
lot of difference because if you have to
twist somebody's arm and stuff when the
when the money is this tight it is
almost it makes it almost it makes a
really tough situation almost impossible
so
if she's willing to do and follow some
instructions and
um
you know she's probably afraid
she's probably got a lot of fun
she's probably afraid
trump's late okay yes has a lot of fear
how long ago did your dad pass
about a month and a half oh my goodness
i'm sorry
wow thank you for that this is very
fresh
okay um do you have any idea what the
balance on the chapter 13 bankruptcy is
to pay it off
about 24
okay
i would use some of your seven i would
use some of your 78 and clear that out
of her life
okay let's see i i talked to the lawyer
just yesterday he says you cannot pay it
off early because you have to pay off
dollar for dollar if you do that way
right now
she's only to pay 27 cents on the dollar
if she
maintains the payments
[Music]
according to the lawyer
um
yeah she's i mean chapter 13 can do a
percentage that's for sure
um
i think i would call chapter 13 trustee
and see if you can work a deal with them
because i i i don't think that's the law
i think that may be a standard but i
think that that can be done
uh to get on out of this if it can't
then you're gonna have to sit and pay it
out because 27 cents is that's a 75
percent increase if you don't write it
out right so you got it right the smart
thing is it is to keep the payments but
you've got that 353 dollar monkey on
your back for the next three years
until well she'll be all right after
that but her major uh in her major debts
or insurances and uh you know things
like that major cause health insurance
for somebody seven years old who's had a
liver transplant you know they they add
up yeah you know but anyway but anyway
so i think you get down on her budget
and comb through it you help her handle
the monthly expenses does she have any
debt that's not in the chapter 13
no no car debt that's in the car that's
in the 13 then
no
everything's paid off i mean everything
i mean
she's doing the best she can now she
does have some things in her budget that
i would say
uh
she needs to get rid of and you know um
and what i'm referring to is she has
access to a property and she pays the
light bill at that at that place and i
told her she needs to get out from under
that because there's you know 60 a month
which isn't a tremendous amount of money
but it's it helps access to a property
what does that mean
uh well
it's family property
and she's agreed to pay the power bill
to it
for access to it
oh i see does that make sense yeah okay
but she doesn't own but she doesn't own
it
no okay no she doesn't need access she's
70.
you have access to the public park yeah
um so that she can't afford it she's
she's a widow that doesn't have any
money and this is a horrible situation
all right so
um i'm going to call the 13 trustee and
see if you can get on out of this if not
here's the deal it's 4 000 a year for
three years it's 12 000
uh is the full payout on it of the 78
i'm just going to bank that to the side
and use that little savings account to
monthly subsidize her income to offset
the bankruptcy being there if you've got
to pay it all the way through does that
make sense
yes yes makes absolute sense and then
and then the rest of it i'm going to
start piling up and trying to create a
way for her to have a life as best she
can uh do you think she would benefit
from going through financial peace
university if you sat and went through
it with her if i give it to you
yeah okay i don't see
well
she'd absolutely benefit from and i want
to throw this at you too we've been
talking to a financial advisor uh
through the bank that she she banks with
and uh he's trying to push her into an
annuity no she puts her
see and i saw your video on annuities
and i said you know what he's going to
shoot me straight
uh
but she'll also don't do it financial
advisors that work at banks aren't real
financial advisors they're bankers
they're salesmen selling products yeah
so you need to get away go you know
here's what we're going to do i'm going
to give you financial peace university
for her to go through free we're also
going to give her free coaching with one
of our coaches
that'll give real advice i didn't try to
sell anything
okay and i'm going to pay for all of it
we're going to take care of her i'm
supposed to take care of widows i'm a
christian so that's what we're going to
do all right so the other man
we'll give you all of that and then you
you your job is to get her to those
people listen with her so she because
she may need an interpreter so to speak
she may need someone to speak it back to
her later
but we'll walk with you and then if you
need investment advice which i don't
think you need much of get with one of
our smart vester pros and they're not
going to put her in an annuity she does
not need to be an annuity with this
amount of money and with this situation
at all she needs much more flexibility
than that is going to give her
and really really dumb butt idea from a
bank investment advisor i hope i wasn't
unclear george very clear okay loud and
clear yeah we need to get the coach to
give you some next steps and that's
where he can come in and help with some
of the homework of you know trying to
get all these expenses down so that we
can live off the 1600 long term yeah
yeah that's the thing and i don't
you know it can be done i don't know
what the rest of the budget looks like
but getting that bankruptcy cleared is
is there
that's really sad it's a tough situation
yeah it is
in those situations when i hear them i
have two sets of emotions and i have for
30 years
set of emotion number one is um i feel
so bad for her
and for the situation that she's in and
i want to help her
but situation number two is it reminds
me how important it is
for me
you and everybody out there listening to
not end up in that situation yeah
to be 70 years old and broke there's no
reason to be there it's not to shame her
or beat up on her but that motivates me
to
not let any of you guys be there
we gotta we gotta if i have to make you
mad if i have to you know uh flop around
and do whatever it is we do around here
to get your attention to get you to save
some money and get out of debt and get
on a budget so that you don't end up in
bankruptcy at 70 years old paying
bankruptcy payments
and and your son's trying to help you
work through this
oh my gosh that's not where you want to
be
and i know it wasn't where she wanted to
be but the thing is you make enough
money to not be broke if you quit
spending it all hello
this is really not rocket science and so
i when i first started this stuff and
when i first started my wealth building
journey
i use those situations as motivation i'm
there i don't i'm not going to be that
person
and it's not to talk bad about them and
it's not to be mean about their
situation i'll help them i love them i'm
sad for them but i'm i'm also going to
use that as motivation as i don't be
there
not in the richest country the world has
ever known yeah there's too much
opportunity and it's not hard the stuff
we teach is so simple and people want to
over complicate it and do the get rich
quick but we say if you just do this for
30 years you're going to be a
millionaire that's it
it's that simple so we get a lot of
calls like this where you have the kind
of sandwich generation where the the son
he's trying to take care of his family
but he's also trying to take care of mom
or dad who didn't handle money the right
way and now they're in a pinch try they
want to help and you could hear it in
his voice he's got a heart to help mom
but there's not a ton he can do we can't
just bankroll their life either
well and it that's you know it starts to
be your only option pretty quick
so when social insecurity is what you're
counting on that is a bad situation hey
folks when the team gets together at
ramsey solutions we talk about our
mission to change situations like that
to change america's toxic culture toxic
money culture toxic relationship culture
toxic job culture and uh
the folks here they don't work at j.o.b
the folks on our team work in mission
this is a mission it's passionate if
you're a ux designer if you're a
developer a writer if you want to help
us build some digital products that
actually do change people's lives so
they don't end up in bad situations and
get out of the bad situations into the
good ones we can show you how
so to see what it's like to do work that
matters with us
before you apply
just uh follow us on instagram and
facebook by searching ramsay careers if
you want to know what's going on with
the job opportunities that are here
you can join the mission not a j-o-b go
to ramseysolutions.com careers we're
hiring about 300 people this year
ramsey solutions.com
careers
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell is with me as my ramsey
personality as my co-host today we're
taking your calls about your life your
money your career
your relationships your
job your
everything in your life
marriage parenting we talk about all of
it right here open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five ryan is in salt lake
city hey ryan welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
so
my wife and i are just about to graduate
with our bachelor's degrees my wife
actually has uh we'll have two um at the
end of april and i'll have uh one hers
will be in nursing
and uh mine will be in exercise and
wellness and i'm about to start
chiropractic school in texas
now
my main question has to do with how to
tackle the student loans
of chiropractic school as they come i've
listened to a lot of your shows on
youtube especially the ones having to do
with chiropractic school i know you
don't have the highest
thoughts about
chiropractic school
but
i
am anticipating taking about a hundred
thousand to 120 000 in student loans
and the reason that that's lower than
what uh the average would be for
chiropractic students is because i've
taken about
i've received about thirty 000 in
academic scholarships for chiropractic
school and my wife will have a job of
about 60 000
a year as a nurse and so those are my
main questions
okay
um
also i don't know if it matters it
doesn't matter my savings is about 35
000. okay how much debt do you guys have
from the schooling so far
we currently have no debt up until this
last or this first semester of
chiropractic school we took out
ten thousand
okay why when you had thirty five
thousand in the bank
we wanted to keep it there
as a safety blanket
if
when we got to texas we wanted to get a
house or also keep it there if down the
road once i start my
business
we have it there for startup costs
okay
um
well i disagree with your strategy
number one i wouldn't buy a house while
you're in the middle of all this
uh you're talking about going 120 000 in
debt to go to school meanwhile buy a
house and meanwhile keep 35 000 to the
side to build a business later no
no
effectively what you're doing is you're
borrowing money not for school but
effectively you're borrowing money to
keep money in your savings account and
you're borrowing money to open your
business later you're borrowing money to
butcher down payment on your house
that's effectively what you're doing so
no if i were you if i woke up in your
shoes and i don't think you're going to
do this because i think you're going to
do your plan but um
so i'm not real sure why you called but
um
but i i would take the 35 000 and put it
towards chiropractic school i'd be
working while i was in chiropractic
school i continue to work on more
scholarships um and i would you know
your wife's going to be picking up a
bunch of overtime to pay for your way
through this school and i'd come out of
chiropractic school with no debt and no
house
that would be my goal yeah i'm hearing
talk about safety and wanting to feel
safe and all this debt is not putting
you in a place of safety it's putting
you at a place of risk and when you get
out you're going to feel broke even as a
chiropractor even with a great income
because you're broke because you're
making payments on 130 000 of debt at
that point while paying a mortgage
payment by the way and property taxes
and insurance costs and home maintenance
costs so now's not the time to be buying
a house i want you to get your career
off the on the right foot pay cash for
this thing and later down the road then
we can get into a house so if i could
put
two of you on two separate tracks
and let's see who wins your track or the
track i just outlined where you use
every dime you can scrape together and
you pay cash and you work your way
through beans and rice rice and beans
and you do anything you can do to create
an income to get your way through but
you don't have a house and you don't
have money to start a business when you
come out but you don't have any debt
versus the plan that you've got where
you've got 120 000 worth of debt 35 000
in the bank and you got a house which
means you don't have 35 000 in the bank
anymore
and your expenses have gone up
if i can take either one of those two
guys and i fast forward them 10 years my
guy will win
you'll end up with the house and owning
your business you might have to work for
someone else for a season to save up the
money to start your business you might
have to work for someone else for a
season to get the house bought but you
won't have any debt hanging around your
neck and every dollar you make will be
free for you to plow into your future in
cash and you cash flow the whole thing
10 years from today ready set go my guy
will win it reminds me of the tortoise
and the hare classic story but we gotta
move slow here and i think there's a
there's a lot of lies that we've
believed especially the younger
generations that dave we deserve a house
we've worked so hard to get through
school and we just deserve the right
yeah i don't even i didn't even hear
entitlement in his voice i just heard he
was trying to be wise he's trying to do
all these smart things and he's trying
to do three different things that are
smart in his mind and doing them in the
wrong order
school
house start a business
and you're trying to do them all at the
same time and in the wrong order and
hold this money and try to make this 35
000 do all that it's not gonna do all
that and it's the same guy who will call
five years later and say hey dave i got
a chiropractic practice and i've got
hundreds of thousand dollars of debt
because i needed to start it for startup
costs what do i do i'm broke yeah and i
don't want that for him so alex or ryan
i'm sorry you you
you're gonna do what you're gonna do and
i got a feeling just from listening to
you you're probably gonna do your plan
but if i if if i could put your twin
brother beside you and he worked my plan
he would beat you
that that i'm telling you that's how
that's how the math will work out and
that's how life will work out robert is
with us in gilbert arizona hi robert how
are you
good dave george how are you guys great
man what's up
uh yeah i have a question um
the question that's in the top of my
mind is and i don't know this there's
such a thing like
being too gazelle intense because right
now like i'm in baby step two and i'm
trying to pay off all the debt but i'm
working from four in the morning to
about ten at night and then by the time
i get home and fall asleep it's like
eleven i gotta wake up by three to go to
work so it's like i'm getting four hours
of sleep at night it's like i'm
constantly feeling tired my body is
feeling the uh the effect of it so it's
like there's such a thing as being too
gazelle intense and how would i like go
around this because i mean
if i keep following this plan i still
won't be out of debt for about another
year year and a half yeah and like your
hours back your hours down dude that's
untenable
that's not
that's not sustainable
intensity is not a number of hours
intensity is focus
right and so what are you making at
these jobs
uh so one of them i make about 70 grand
the other one to make about 35.
okay not bad
so that's nice and the good news is
you'll be done a year and a year and a
half but uh i mean two hours three hours
of sleep if that's really what's going
on if you're not exaggerating that
that's not sustainable the human body
can't do that
instead i mean i've only been doing it
for a month and i can already tell it's
not sustainable yeah you're not getting
enough you're not getting enough rest
you're not you're gonna have a car wreck
or something you're not gonna function
okay right yeah my only thing was like
if i back down the hours uh you gotta
back down the hours
okay and then just just take on being in
debt a little bit longer if it costs you
two months and you're alive then that's
okay
but i mean i don't you don't have to
back them down you don't cut you don't
have to drop one of the jobs entirely
but you got to get some more sleep you
got to have a little bit more risk if
that's really what's going on if you're
not being a drama queen exaggerating
but because i don't know how you did
that for a month now
that's pretty wild but if you do if
you're really doing that i would back
that off but intensity is about focus
and everything else to the exclusion
it's not about the number of hours
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five over the last 30 years i've
walked with millions of people and their
families to help them overcome financial
stress but that's just one of the kinds
of stress that's out there
certainly in the last couple of years a
lot of people have had anxiety
loneliness
all kinds of things are popping up and
it's uh it's a bit of a
mental health pandemic out there dr john
dolone has a new book available for
pre-order called own your past
change your future it's selling like
crazy everyone wants and needs to know
about dr delony's not so complicated
approach to relationships mental health
and wellness and you're in for a treat
this book is a life-changing
book it's uh pretty stinking incredible
own your past to change your future
you're going to laugh you're going to
cry you're going to be challenged
i was when i read the manuscript and if
you take the steps dr deloney outlines
you're going to be transformed how to
deal with different kinds of trauma how
to get connected to a community the
steps you take to change your thoughts
and actions yes this is all possible
your mental health is real and it's
really important so pre-order today
you're going to get free bonus items
including a month of free one-on-one
weekly therapy through our friends and
partners at betterhelp who does that a
whole month
well that's included in a twenty dollar
pre-order for this book we want you to
have everything you need to be well so
pre-order your copy comes out in april
of own your past change your future it's
only twenty dollars while on pre-order
and you get the month of one-on-one
therapy from better help so check it all
out at ramseysolutions.com
today
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell is with us david is with us
david is in louisville kentucky hi david
how are you
i'm doing well and uh thanks for taking
my call dave and george i appreciate
your guys's wisdom and opinion so i'll
try to be brief and um
uh a little groundwork i'm an
over-the-road truck driver uh i am out
five days at a time and i have rotating
weekends my wife works full-time
i would say two full-time jobs she also
takes care of our kids all week while
i'm gone
um so we have a 20 month old and we have
a second baby boy coming in nine days
wow
so yeah mama's got her hands full um i
try to help while i'm there and this job
does have predictable schedules uh which
really helped a lot but here's what
happened uh
a lot of relational stuff and a little
financial thing but i i do wonder your
thoughts on the financial thing so
when we put the second car seat in the
uh she had a small suv
i was the one who said you know this
thing's a little tighter than it needs
to be in here for you having to pack
them out in and out all day by yourself
we might look at some other options
so we talked about it could not agree on
makes models anything i'm looking at
minivans she's looking at suvs
we actually went and physically looked
at some cars just to get some ideas um
try to compromise on things
and there was a little compromise on
cars you know different makes and models
and then we were trying to figure out
what would be realistic in our range
with the trade and all that and
there were several we both got a little
uh sticker
eyeballs there and then tried to back
away from that
and there were several talks about you
know we're not going to finance anything
different than where we are now
to get into the vehicle we need to be
you know a lateral move is fine but
we're not going to go backwards
next thing i know saturday she sends me
pictures of this van that she just went
and picked up
and uh financed 10 grand
we owed five as it was on the corner and
we had the money to pay it off we were
doing the stork mode thing um
and i don't know
i don't know if she just
had a change of heart we had a
commitment conversation last night and
we agreed there's a lot of individual
and relational counseling needed to
figure out how we even got to where we
thought this was a good idea
my thought on the financial side is we
turn right back around and sell that van
and whatever the gap money is
between the sell and paying off the loan
that's what we go by um
she seems to still think i don't know at
what level that this was a good idea and
that we should keep it uh that it's just
five grand further backwards
um and that we can we can pay it off if
we buckle down so i'm curious what your
thought is there
wow
um
well i'm vacillating between this ladies
completely overwhelmed with two little
uh babies she's pregnant
and and the fact that she completely
lost her dadgum mind
and went again and and went against
everything in the relationship lied to
her husband
and acted like she wasn't even married
um so i mean part of me simply
sympathetic to where she is and how
overwhelmed she is and i get all of that
but part of me is really ticked at her
right now
and suppose and i suppose you're
probably 10x of both of those
exactly and and i do understand on the
one hand
and not necessarily even my bigger
vehicle
is the right choice of vehicle the loan
is completely separate from that
well and it does but this
decision-making process that is
completely out of control
you're not going to ever have anything
financially
until we solve whatever is broken there
in her
uh in her mind on how relationships work
um so
i um
uh
yeah financially what you need to do
sell the car
and you need to get a car that you can
afford
um and also that would probably be a
good idea for her to
do
to recommit to your marriage not
necessarily to the ramsey steps or
something you guys may decide together
that you want to go deeply in debt if
you want to do that that's fine but
whatever the first thing that has to
happen is you all have to get on the
same page and agree to keep your word to
each other
you just can't have a relationship where
you just
don't keep your word to each other or
where you act independently unilaterally
of each other like this
there's there's just no data that says
that creates a quality relationship yeah
the financial piece can be undone today
but the
relational piece the trust that's going
to take a while to build back up and i
think you're right that counseling is in
order and on the financial side do you
guys still have other types of debt
outside of this car loan yeah how much
how much a little bit yeah they're
working we're working baby step two
we're close we had yeah we had five
grand left on the cars this current car
is now 10 so an additional five or six
um she has a
17 000 student loan which would have
been the next thing we tackled and then
some petty collections that she has from
old credit cards yeah
uh my guess is my guess is your wife
feels like that she's been running her
life by herself already
for a long time because you're just
never there
and um she feels abandoned and she just
had to do what she had to do as an
abandoned single mom i'm thinking that's
where she is emotionally
you don't feel like that's where she is
but i think that's where she thinks she
is
i agree with that that that that's
probably pretty fair for how she feels
emotionally i guess my concern is you
know i don't downplay that at all but
at least relationally and financially
we've agreed to be on the same page and
then you went and did yeah i mean i i i
i'm i'm livid of her breaking her word
and and just doing this but i'm trying
to figure out what level of
distress she must have been in to do
that because it sounds like you all had
very clear conversations and then she
just went and did whatever the flip she
wanted to do anyway so which just tells
me she's just in freak out mode
i guess
i mean because i i don't this lady does
not sound like someone who is
obstinate arrogant
she doesn't sound like that person to me
she sounds more like somebody who feels
i think she's a cornered animal and she
bit you
you know what i'm saying
yeah that's how it feels so you got to
get to the bottom of that before you can
fix this van thing the van problem is
that is the symptom it's not the thing
so
and it may be dude you're coming off the
road you got little babies
and she she's overwhelmed
and you may be coming off the road and
doing something else so that you can be
there for your family for a season
i don't know but i do know you need to
sit down the marriage counselor for sure
i'm not qualified to unravel all this i
can just i can kind of get on her side
for a minute but there's no way to
justify what she did on the other hand
so i can get on your side and be pissed
about it too i get it i understand where
your head is but i'm trying to figure
out what caused this so it doesn't
happen again
that's the thing because if you don't
break this you're gonna be broke your
whole life
so yeah sit down with a good marriage
counselor my friend
this is the ramsey show
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
um
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
so george i saw you doing a thing the
other day um
you're like a hacks guy i mean you find
all these shortcuts and these
deals and these ways to do things and
you and rachel were doing some on the
grocery store that were really really
popular and um you were telling me a few
minutes ago
and i thought let's just tell everybody
uh they share this
number one we are not kidding when we
say in baby step one
two and three
you don't need to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
until you're out of debt
because restaurant food is entertainment
it is not nutrition
if you want to spend one-fourth of what
you spend at the restaurant you will
have a better meal when you learn to
cook at home
okay so it's not about it's economics if
you want to do entertainment you do
entertainment when you're not broke and
in debt and don't have an emergency fund
so when you finish baby step three
though
and you're in four five six running
simultaneously yes we go on vacation yes
we go into restaurants and we're not
against restaurants sharon and i will
eat at a restaurant this week i suspect
maybe i don't know sometime but i mean
we you know we're not every night people
like some of you so but but
so we're not anti-restaurant and i have
one guys in the restaurant business you
don't like people in the restaurant i
love the restaurant business i just
don't want people broke people going in
there yes so anyway once you're not
broke people you've got some ideas on
how to save some money some savings
hacks especially on some of these quick
serves yes and now we're not talking
like bottom of the barrel fast food here
because it's hard to beat the taco bell
one dollar menu there's not a lot
there's you can't hack it much yeah
there's a can of alpo beats that exactly
well there's not much real meat in there
i'm just saying some of these fast
casual places you know the paneras the
chipotles starbucks chick-fil-a i put
chick-fil-a in another tier i don't know
i agree and panera i wouldn't agree it's
a level of almost anything in another
tier from taco bell there you go all
right so uh do you want to do a choose
your own adventure are you a fan of any
of those
uh i can't see you frequenting any of
these i'm not i'm not a fr i'm not the
customer and i'm not the focus group so
you just plow right in okay well most of
america maybe steps into a starbucks at
some point apparently they're on every
freaking corner they're everywhere so
i'll give you some some hacks here for
starbucks because some of y'all are
getting eight dollar drinks at starbucks
that don't even have coffee in them it's
just sugar and water and it's just real
fancy and you add whipped cream on top
and you go happy to give you eight bucks
so here's here's some hacks
okay number one become a rewards member
this is completely free there's no
credit card involved all you do is you
sign up to become a rewards member and
you get free refills on your brewed
coffee uh you get exclusive offers you
get a free drink on your birthday and
you can get any drink dave you can get a
ten dollar drink on your birthday if you
want to there you go so what's up
it's not it's not starbucks is 10 bucks
exactly they're increasing the prices so
that's uh number one
number two get caffeine for cheap if
you're just going to get the caffeine uh
you want that bump you want that
adrenaline rush then avoid all the fancy
drinks and get the brewed coffee and
here's why it has more caffeine than any
of their other drinks a tall a tall
coffee that's the small one dave i know
it's confusing small tall
you don't think of that when you think
of me i'm a size tall
in height there you go i'm just saying
that has 235 milligrams of caffeine
aventi latte has 150. that's confusing i
saw the cartoon the other day the
editorial got the guys up at the burrito
with the barissa and she turns around to
the other guy and goes do we have a
flavor called regular coffee
yeah
so there you go it's hard to find these
days so go for the brewed coffee it's
the cheapest thing on the menu and it
has the most caffeine so don't come at
me in the comments there number three
there's a drink that's even smaller than
the tall and get this dave it's called
short
who knew who knew and this is a tiny
drink but you can get the same amount of
espresso in there for a cheaper price or
you get your brewed coffee at a cheaper
price if you really are on a budget and
you want to save some money with all
this inflation stuff going around ask
for a short you can ask for it in a tall
cup that way there's some room at the
top there you might get a little more
bang for your buck
number four split aventi now dave i'm
trying to help you with the sizes here
the venti is the big one okay so if you
and sharon are gonna get the same drink
instead of you both getting a drink and
paying 10 bucks split a venti and then
pour it into an empty cup sounds
romantic so romantic you can drink from
the same straw if you want you can still
do that with both cups i don't know what
you and sharon do these days to keep the
the spark alive
i'm guessing no just keep moving on
george
that's fun and the last one here is go
light on the ice you can ask for light
ice or no water added and you get way
more in there you ever take a drink of
something dave and it's just all lush
it's four pounds of ice in there yeah
and your drink was over in 10 seconds
and you go wow that's kind of an old
fast food trick yeah fill the cup up
with ice cream that's how i feel about
cocktails too you take four sips and
it's gone you went that was 20 bucks
yeah that's because you're a guzzler
that's right so ask for light ice or no
water added and you will get more bang
for your buck so there's some easy
starbucks hacks and i know a lot of
people give me another one we got we got
just a minute give me another okay
one more starbucks no no no no another
another company go to
chick-fil-a everybody loves jesus
chicken right here we go one of my
favorites obviously download the
chick-fil-a one app become a rewards
member all that good stuff but here's
the thing dave i order a kids meal
because calorically it's still way more
calories than any adult needs how am i
not supposed to say anything
dave how is it possible i can pass that
by do it here's the deal with the kids
meal you get a drink you get your fries
and you can swap with a toy for an ice
cream
dave is breathing so heavily right now
but here's the deal
it's five dollars and you get your food
you get your nuggets whatever you want
for about five bucks another one day
feels like you're cheating to me you
ready for this you can order a blt at
chick-fil-a
yeah but you're a chick-fil-a i know but
dave here's the thing it's a dollar
sixty you get bread
it's a toasted toasted bun with bacon
lettuce tomato so i'm just saying if
you're on a budget you got two bucks to
blow and i gotta try that because their
food quality is so good on everything
else i'll give that a shot yeah and you
know what dollar the sauce is free the
sauce is free pour all the sauce you
want on there it probably don't need to
probably okay dollar sixty though cause
what you're paying for the sandwich is
the chicken you're paying for the filet
so when you take that out it brings the
cost way down so there's a lot more dave
we could go all day but i can tell you
you're frustrated already no i'm just
i'm i'm
i'm not frustrated i'm just interested
it's um
it's um you know what america wants to
see me and you driving down to
chick-fil-a down the road here and
ordering yeah i think that's our next
video together yeah what do you think
probably not okay it's a good effort i
just wanted to see dave roll up in his
mean old truck ordering a kids meal for
himself
that is the content america needs right
now dave well that would end up on
youtube fraud fraud ramses if he's not a
child he just ordered a kid's meal and
he's not a child i'll be next to you
yeah as your child that's no i'm that's
it's okay it's all good i'll take a
grandkid and use them as a prop that's
perfect yeah you're posting kids you got
to get some value out of them so well
i'm just here to save the people a
dollar and here's the thing it's not
about so what's the ones for panera
panera they've got a new value duet
piece they used to have a you pick too
now it's good they have a value duet so
it's six seven bucks and you can get you
know a soup and a sandwich oh
that's the duet and you can ask for a
lot of free toppings which is great so
you can double the size of your sandwich
by adding all of these free toppings in
there so we'll pick up a bunch of panera
sometime on a trip and just put it about
you know and they throw stuff in they're
pretty generous
with the add-on stuff all that bread is
cheap they'll throw a bunch well it's
not just the bread i mean they're chips
they're pretty they don't they're not um
they're not
there's a lot of value
in general and the food again they're
like chick-fil-a i think food quality is
pretty good for a fast serve quick serve
or whatever you call them and they have
a new sip club so you get unlimited
coffee for an entire month or you know
iced coffee hot tea for 8.99 so if you
go to panera frequently you're used on
your way to work for nine bucks a month
you can get as much coffee as you want
you can go every two hours if you want
to how does that not
beat all of your starbucks hacks well i
prefer the the quality of the coffee at
starbucks oh you like the burnt dark
roast that's right well i get the blonde
rose dave if you're if you want to get
particular here okay all right
so
there it is so but so panera is not like
dunkin donuts they don't have world
famous coffee see donuts coffee's
supposed to be a big deal too right yeah
i'm from boston and so my bostonians
will say duncan beats everyone but
really they're just pouring cream and
sugar in it and calling it coffee so
sorry what's the difference in that
starbucks well i drink it black dave i'm
one of those hipster types oh okay yeah
okay yeah you like a little sugar in
your coffee america wants to know i'm a
hardcore i mean super strong
like you just need to stand a stick up
you want it mine don't want anything in
it no nothing
no nothing as a matter of fact i'll take
a coffee and throw an espresso in it wow
the red eye that's what they call it
yeah okay i didn't know it had a name
you were cool before it was cool no i'm
not never never that was never on the
list well it was just it was just a lot
of caffeine involved let me know if you
use the hacks and you save a buck it'll
make me feel good i'll sleep well at
night yeah well thanks for the service
george welder to help this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host before we go back to the phones
george i have to know this we have the
fresh ground
you select the size you select which
type of coffee you want
machines all through the building
um i it the for 1200 employees it would
have been an extra 25 000 a year for us
to put starbucks in them so we didn't
wow it has regular good quality coffee
in it but it is not starbucks uh it's
not a brand name so save the twenty
thousand bucks and use that to do other
things for the team other than other
because coffee's free when you work here
and so it's an amazing person
in the old uh yeti here the ramsay yeti
every day
is uh uber strong as strong as you can
make it
hard ground you know medium right just
put it in black coffee so what's in
yours i've got water here dave do you do
you
do you hit that machine
i do i love the machine and i i we have
brewed coffee oh we have great brewed
coffee out there i just don't take time
to go out there and get it in the in the
top of that you spoiled us with an
actual coffee bar
that has fancy drinks that's true we pay
for those but they're so subsidized that
it's like a dollar fifty for a latte so
that's true you can get a lot you can
get the big time stuff there but so you
don't hit them because this machine is
world it's really amazing yeah that's
what i drink okay then they've got
different it's completely free when you
work here so that's a hack right
absolutely okay here's the truth dave i
don't make coffee at home because i come
into work and i get my cup of coffee oh
there we go so you're like those people
that plug their cars in outside and get
free free fuel you know i'm not an
electric car guy dave i can't get for
free but i don't have you don't get free
gas if you work here but you get free
electricity that's right i've heard you
do not understand that either it adds up
all right alex is with us in austin
texas hey alex what's up
hey how are you dave great man how can
we help
yeah so the reason i called is because
i'm in need of a bit of career advice
okay so i'm 24 years old i don't have
any loan from undergrad and i plan on
starting pharmacy school later this fall
great but most of the pharmacists that
i've spoken to tell me that the field is
no longer worth it
and it's not what it was before
it's becoming really saturated uh the
job outlook is projected to go down
significantly
and also the pay has decreased at least
for like retail pharmacists entry-level
pharmacist
and so i just don't want to go into
something and regret it for the next
you know however many years
if i'm not going to be sure if i i can
pay off all those loans yeah with those
type of projections and that's
interesting i have not i have not heard
that i did i didn't you know what i
don't doubt it with the cvs's and the
walgreens entering that space and
largely controlling that space as one of
the major employers um
and it's you know the the and the drug
space in general is moving pretty
rapidly uh
generics and and discounts programs and
uh the the
um cuban just did a thing with drugs and
and there was a deal and so yeah that's
interesting i i kind of don't doubt what
you've heard i don't know that
personally but it doesn't it doesn't
sound like it's outlandish to me
so let's let's say all of that's true
what are you gonna do
so yeah so that's part of the reason why
i was calling because um
uh if i've been listening to your show
in like these last couple two weeks i
started listening
and you know all these people getting
into debt they're not being able to pay
it off yeah so that's probably like i
guess there's a fear factor especially
since i haven't had any loans from
undergrad what is your undergrad um
biochemistry
okay
so you're you're obviously
what's your gpa
3.8 from undergrad good for you okay
well there's a lot of stuff you could do
with that it doesn't have to be pharmacy
it's just that's been your dream a long
time and now talking about changing
horses is scary as crud isn't it
yeah so everything i've done has led to
that and there really hasn't been like a
plan b
yeah
so i don't know if i should stick with
this and hope for the best no
i think you need to play i think you
need to pan back and develop a plan b
and that'll help you decide if you're
going to stick with it
let me give you a decision-making tool i
use in all major decisions and i use it
in business i use it personally okay
i always want a lot
of options
the more options i have the better
decision i'm going to make because in
developing the options
i learn a lot about all of the paths in
other words while you're developing
option bcde
you're going to learn about pharmacy
things you didn't know today and and
when you feel like you have one possible
path and you're stuck on that path that
seldom results in a good decision
especially when you've got
data and evidence telling you making you
question your decision
and so an example would be years ago i
got ready to lease a building for this
business okay i had one i had my eye on
and i liked it and i thought that was
the right way to go
but instead of just doing that i went
and became an expert on every building
in a 10 mile radius that was for rent
what the rent was what the square
footage available was what the build-out
cost was going to be and i spreadsheeted
all of it and i put all of this data
down there and then the gathering of all
of that the decision rose up and it
actually was not the building i thought
it was
we ended up going with building b rather
than building a
and it turned out to be one of the best
real estate deals i've ever done in my
life
but i changed i did change course and
the reason i changed course was in the
development of other options because i
refused to make a decision where there's
only one
option and so that's that when people
say for instance even in a dating
relationship there's only one girl on
the planet that god has for me
you're you're screwed
because that's just not true number one
uh number two you you just you just
talked your way into marrying crazy or
something's what you just did and that's
a bad idea you know so
i think you may end up back at pharmacy
but george i think he needs a bunch of
options yeah i was telling him he needs
to go into research mode and figure out
what are all of the options based on my
undergrad what are all the schools in
the area who's willing to give me
scholarships what kind of offers am i
getting versus backing yourself into a
corner and going well this is it i gotta
take it
anyways ken coleman's get clear
assessment i like that hold on i'm going
to give you that okay it's like a 30
thing on our website or whatever it is
20 or something just take this quick
assessment it's going to help you get
clear and it'll give you some output
it'll give you some ideas of things to
think about and look at and um i'm even
gonna go and give you ken's book uh from
paycheck to purpose because i think
that's what's going on but for sure take
that get clear assessment and maybe even
call the ken coleman show and talk to
him after you've done this because i
i'm not saying that i that that i don't
i told you early in the conversation i
don't have personal knowledge that
pharmacy's dead but what he's saying
does it does
it does smell right yeah and so i want
to look into all the options and i know
that like you said dave
we we have to shift gears here and go
maybe pharmacy school isn't the thing
that i always thought it was going to be
and now i've got a switch and maybe i go
into research or maybe i go into a
different industry that can be a hard
pill to swallow but i don't want him
calling back five years from now going
dave i regret it i'm 200 000 in debt and
i don't even want to be a pharmacist
well and he's got the he's got the gray
matter to to be a scientist or do
anything he's going to do with what he's
talking about so there's a lot of
different things that directions he can
go it just depends on what you want to
do with your life what do you want when
you come home at night and you're tired
is it a good tired
you know
like you know did you feel like you
accomplished something are you working
at something that you're passionate
about and um
you know uh you and i finish uh doing
one of these live events and you know
we've been on stage for a couple hours
or whatever and we come off we're tired
uh we fish doing a three-hour show we're
tired it takes more energy to do a
three-hour show doesn't work eight hour
day
and so um but that's a good tire because
stuff we love doing yeah and that's what
ken talks about all the times being
plugged into something you love doing
it's a great assessment i took it myself
uh and uh i'm in the right field dave
good i want you to know that well i i i
said i feel really better because i was
i was worried about that
it said you should be a pharmacist no
i'd be terrible i'll leave that to our
other friend on the line here yeah
yeah you may end up there but uh i'm
gonna do i'm gonna explore some options
because here's the thing
if you do end up back there and you have
looked at all the options you will be
sure it will have pushed the doubt aside
and um
you know i i don't know how many
pharmacists you talk to to get this
information either i might talk to a few
more
try to find someone who's actually happy
they did it and ask them why these other
people are wrong well if you ask
teachers if i should go be a teacher
they'll probably tell you right now the
ones you talk to say ah don't do it
but does that mean teaching is a bad
profession you shouldn't get into it
might be the thing you're called to do
that's true and so that's it's a tough
thing you got to watch out who you
listen to as well yeah that's true
because but but yeah
you need to gather more information
yeah it sounds like you have a limited
thing here it just but it knocked you
off your kilter because you had you had
one thing you were doing and it was like
this doesn't happen that's it i'm with
you man hey i hope i hope that works out
for you hang on kelly i'll pick up we'll
give all that to you as our gift
this
is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world get your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host he's also the host of the ramsey
network podcast
called fine print where he investigates
the fine print where you people are
being screwed and he lets you know where
that's happening so it stops happening
once you have that knowledge how
powerful is that be sure and check that
podcast out the first season is all
online and ready to pick up everywhere
great podcasts are available just go to
ramsey networks anywhere you want and we
can help you line it up the fine print
just search the fine print jennifer's
with us in phoenix to start off this
hour hi jennifer how are you
i'm good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so last year my husband and i were
separated we were going through a
divorce
uh he ended up passing away unexpectedly
and um
yeah um so i am actually taking his
social security for my kids
and there's actually quite a bit of
money for them and i was just wondering
what i should do with that to best grow
it for when they're ready for it
well i
i have an unusual answer on that that a
lot of people don't agree with um
you are spending more on those children
than this money is to raise them
yeah well
it's quite a lot of money yeah i am no
it's not that much money
i mean what is it 500 bucks a month or
something
no it's 2500 each okay 2 500 bucks a
month okay yeah but it costs more than
that to raise a kid
what is your household income
about
yeah okay
and so this is uh 30 000 bucks a kid so
60 000 bucks is that included in the is
a 60 000 including that 115
no okay so you have 60 000 plus 115
coming into your house
how old are the kids
they are nine and thirteen okay all
right
so um
if i were in your situation
i would be providing for my kids which
i'm sure you are
and that would include saving for their
college
you may not be doing that yet
and that would include getting our
family out of debt so that we can save
for their college and that would include
getting our family out of debt so that
you retire with dignity so they don't
you don't have to have them support you
when you're old
um
and it was in other words it would have
a whole financial plan for your whole
family
that encompasses taking care of your
kids does that make sense
yes and so if i were in your shoes i
would have a 160 000 budget to do that
with
and you know now i i you know if you're
gonna go snort the money with cocaine or
something then i'm not going to tell you
to do that you should set the money
aside for the kids you're not taking
care of your kids but if you're taking
care of your kids and you're a good mom
which i suspect you are
then
your kids are going to be just fine and
you didn't steal from them because
you're spending this much on them anyway
and probably as much as comes in is
going to be spent on them and or saved
for them out of a normal family budget
so i don't i don't distinguish it i
don't set it aside
same thing with child support i don't
set it aside as only for the children
buying electricity is for the children
keeping shingles on the roof
is for the children
uh having an emergency fund is for the
children
running your family properly your
children benefit from in other words
uh greatly and so that's what i would
the way i would look at it i would just
say it's part of your budget just like i
would child support george you got any
suggestions well i like the idea of just
making it part of her budget and this is
money to take care of them versus
setting it aside and one day she gives
them a pile of money and says hey go
have fun look what the government gave
you and so for the next decade as
they're under your roof potentially i
want you to make sure that we're taking
care of the household and their their
needs are covered and maybe you help
them with a car purchase one day you do
the 401 dave plan you save half they
save up half i want them to still build
those financial muscles so that they're
adults whenever they do leave the house
regardless of how much money and you're
not going to build your household where
you are counting on
their social security number to pay your
bills
you're you're building you're you're
you've got a household you're taking
care of your kids and the social
security money is coming in so when it
stops it's not a big deal
that that's the other thing uh and that
tells you you're doing it right in other
words but if you're if you're dreading
them leaving because the money's gonna
leave when they do
uh that means you have a broken budget
and you got some other stuff to deal
with here but yeah and it you know so
yeah i'd walk right up the baby steps
make sure you're out of debt have your
emergency fund in place and then you
start your retirement 15 going in you
start funding their kids college you're
going to set aside money for their cars
as they come up and match them on their
cars like you said what we do on cars uh
jennifer is we match we don't buy them a
car we whatever they save we'll put with
it
and and i'd put a limit on that because
if you run into one of them as a little
saver then you'd have a deal but this
money can be used for that
so hang on i'm going to send you a copy
of the book smart money smart kids that
was the number one bestseller that
rachel and i did together it's on how to
teach your kids how to handle money
because your family is going to be in
really good shape financially because
you've got a really big income if you'll
lean in and manage it properly and you
need to teach your kids how to handle
money because they're going to have some
as a result of all of this
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five evan is in
harrisburg pennsylvania hi evan what's
up
hi dave and george thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
i just had a tax question um my wife and
i always usually get a refund so i'm
looking at adjusting uh her w-4 she's
the only one that works is i'm a
stay-at-home dad
so
we had our daughter
last year so that kind of i tried to
adjust it but i was still off and now we
just welcomed
a baby boy on february 15th so now we're
going to have another child for next tax
season so i didn't know where that kind
of fits with everything
how should i be adjusting
her w-4 to try to take
take home more how much was your refund
in the last three years give me the last
three years
uh actually the
uh last three
it was like
7
thousand
it's uh six thousand and this year was
forty three hundred
well you didn't shop much off did you
no
okay
well you so so we know if if nothing
changed and something has changed but to
the good but we know if nothing changed
your 400 bucks a month off right
okay yeah
so um just change the w4 by 400 bucks
that's an easy one the second thing you
can do to get closer with the new
arrival and all is just run
a uh a tax return for next year
as if uh for 2022. go ahead go ahead and
do your tax return right now as if this
was the income
and and do a pretend tax return you're
not going to file this tax return but
what you're trying to determine is what
actual taxes you're going to might owe
in 2022 with the things that are the way
they are right now
do a faux tax return does that make
sense for 22
for 22.
and uh you use a 21 form to do it but
you're just doing it for an exercise and
that says you owe
however many dollars in taxes divided by
12 is how much a month should be coming
out of that w-4 yeah she just needs to
connect with hr and figure out what the
protocol is for changing that i've done
it recently on our software here myself
and you just adjust the number yeah you
can adjust the number by number you
don't have to do it by dependence
because the defendant's thing with the
irs is
completely inaccurate it's not accurate
at all this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today it's tax season and i
don't know anyone who loves that
unless you're an accountant
and maybe even then you don't love it
the truth is most of us dread filing our
taxes i'm always pissed off around this
time of year
it's a pain it's confusing and if filing
taxes wasn't bad enough the tax software
people use hits you with the extra fees
or worse they try to sell you on a bunch
of debt and other stuff you weren't
there for that you're just trying to do
your stinking taxes but filing your
taxes does not have to be that horrible
we created ramsey smart tax to give you
software that you can trust we don't
sell your name to scum burgers and not
gonna try to sell you debt and there's
no extra unwritten fees that just pop up
smart tax has steps that are simple and
clear you know you've done your taxes
right
no more headaches no more second
guessing yourself we'll never tack on a
surprise fee or sell your info to scummy
companies when you sign up for ramsey
plus it's even easier ramsay plus
members get ramsey smart tax for federal
taxes for free
wow so if you want to get a free trial
to ramsey plus for
you know just go to ramsey solutions dot
com slash ramsey plus when you're ramsey
plus member you can use the smart tax
for free that's a good idea people
that's a good idea that's kind of like
one of georgia's hacks right there
there's a life hack for you a life hack
that's good our question today comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and the new promos
all the time great american company
blinds.com always use the promo code
ramsey
today's question comes from tom in
louisiana he says i'm 32 years old
married with one child and another on
the way
i have a mechanical engineering degree
and have worked as a project manager for
the past three years we are debt free
except for our 158 000 mortgage and we
have 35 000 saved in retirement during
the pandemic i lost my job where i
earned 97 000 a year i applied for
numerous positions with no success so i
lowered my expectations to look for
lower paying opportunities i received
and accepted a job offer as a project
manager at a non-profit this position
pays me 67 000 with no benefits however
to my surprise i really enjoy this
position and the environment am i
settling should i continue to look for
bigger and better jobs with actual
benefits such as insurance and 401k
yes i would continue to look i think
it's great that he loves it but i i
don't think this is the the end game
long term
there's a false dichotomy that pops up a
lot
and the false dichotomy is is that the
only way i can find a job in an
environment that i love is if i'm
underpaid
then that's just not true
you can make actually great
at a company you love
and that you know that the environment
is awesome you just have to look for it
and find it
those things are actually out there
there are good companies and that are
not nonprofits and they do a good job
we're one of them by the way with
benefits we don't hire uh you know we
don't have any mechanical engineers here
so i can't help you with that but
but the uh but but the point being that
and our people are paid market and above
you know our pay grade here we go
constantly doing compensation studies to
make sure we're paying what the market
is
saying someone that position that type
of thing is worth we want to be at least
at that if not better
um
and and you know we work really really
hard so that is it possible i i think um
i think you had it went through a scary
time
and um it probably
took some of your confidence away
it feels to me like you know this is
safe
and you don't want to stick your hand
out there in the cold again
you got tired of being cold and i don't
blame you for that
but um i i i think you've created then a
false narrative that's not true yeah
that would be false in other words yeah
and project managers are in high demand
even in louisiana i think you can do
better than 67 000 with benefits and so
there's nothing wrong with working at
this non-profit and enjoying that but i
still would be looking for the other
opportunities
i think you're probably worth 110 in the
market and you just got to find some
place that's not a toxic environment and
you're not taking it just for the money
you're taking it because it's work you
like with a place you like oh and by the
way they pay really well oh and by the
way they have good benefits but no i
don't i don't ever want someone to take
a job just for money and put up with
horrible situation or i hate my life or
whatever it's not a ken coleman thing
it's not a ramsay thing
so uh no i wouldn't do that but
the false dichotomy is is that the only
thing you only only get one the only
place you can work that's good is if
you're underpaid and that's just not a
that's not a true thing uh not a true
thing at all
generally speaking you're going to
really get paid it
uh really well it's something you
actually love in an environment you love
that's not
you you don't have to settle to have
meaning
uh settle on the income side to have
meaning that's just not a true thing
good question very interesting
interesting brandon is with us in idaho
hi brandon welcome to the ramsay show
hi can you hear me sure what's up
all right
so my father passed away about two weeks
ago oh my god
wow how old are you
i'm 34. man i'm so sorry what happened
thank you
it was uh related to covid
and then about
a week and a half before that both my
grandparents died within about four days
of each other oh my goodness um
so
brandon i'm sorry well my my stepmom
which was my dad's wife
um
she has no income at all
and my dad left behind
he had no will
no life insurance no
savings
and we're wondering kind of what to take
to do to take care of her
short term and long term who's we
long term we may
my siblings and i
there's four of us and they're you're
all there all of you are um
she's yours all of your stepmom
none of them are her kids she's
uh two of them are her kids okay so she
has two biological children and two
stepchildren you're one of the step
children
yeah and my dad adopted her two children
so
okay cool that's wonderful i'm just
trying to get a handle on what's going
on here and how old is she yeah
she's 58 okay and what does she do for a
living she has
she has no income she
my dad took care of her
she didn't have a job or anything so
she does have some health things
back problems and
joint problems and stuff so
she has no income
she needs more will she needs an income
yeah
that's the first thing we will be from
what my grandparents
my grandparents they passed away
and
possibly from there and they have
we may be inheriting i think the way
their will is written
is that they're my dad's portion of
their inheritance may go towards
to us kids
which may be around 100 to 150 000
split up between us that's not gonna
last that's not gonna last 10 minutes
your mom your mom needs a job dude
and that's that's harsh one week after
your dad died and a week after your
grandparents died
um
but the
the reality is is that they didn't set
themselves up for that for her to work
at to not work at 58 years old so she
gets to work
he does have a truck that
yes owes 35 000 on the truck
and it's probably worth around 50 000.
sell it we're planning on selling that
good uh we have to wait for death
certificates for that but we're planning
on selling that right away good
she can't afford it she didn't have any
money and she didn't have a job
do they have a house
uh they have a property uh that my dad
was in the middle of
uh
building on the house or building on the
property it's 78 acres about two hours
north of where i live where does she
live
she was living on it with my dad in a uh
in a camper while they were building on
it okay she needs to get an apartment
you all need to sell that property
this is a horrible thing your family's
going through brandon but it's going to
get worse
fast
if you all don't make some decisive
action and she gets to work and she gets
in an apartment because you're gonna
burn through that hundred grand in about
20 minutes and you have nothing and
she's still going to be sitting there
with a bigger problem then without any
options sell that property sell that
truck get her an apartment get her into
a career and let's have chapter two and
that's harsh to say one week later i'm
so sorry but that's your reality
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five
two two
five
so george i think um
you said a minute ago during the break
that this is a
a good opportunity to kind of revisit
that last call okay because there's a
lot of sadness there and we were short
on time and so i was hitting the guy
pretty much between the eyes so four
kids left with a 58 year old stepmom mom
she's got a half done construction
project on 78 acres and a truck she
can't afford and she does not work and
there's no money
the kids are being left from the
grandparents a hundred and something
thousand dollars
and so
here's what
unless something really weird happens if
the kids rally around decide that
they're going to take care of mom so
that the 58 year old woman does not have
to work which i completely disagree with
by the way i was pretty obvious about
that but um
then they're going to burn through the
money
and then they're going to be forced to
still address the exact same issue
and one or two of them are going to
start bailing out because their spouses
are not going to participate in this
enabling mom to do nothing thing
um
and so she's got some health issues
she's got some limitations on her career
field probably uh somehow i doubt she's
probably going to be carrying steel on
the construction site but
that's not an issue there's other things
you can do
uh that are not physical labor yeah um
[Music]
lots of things in the digital world that
we're in that you can develop and do
and so if i'm spending money on mom it's
to give her tools to win and create
sustainability for my skill set because
i love her not because i'm greedy and i
don't want to take care of her that's
not the point
um
and so
here's
everyone needs a will
and everyone needs a plan
if you're going to die this year
what happens to your family if you die
this year
and if you're 32 years old and you have
two little kids you don't have to have a
two and a half hour meeting about this
every year
but you do need a two and a half minute
meeting
to review where everything is
that there's a will there's life
insurance in place
there's um this is what happens if
something happens in the middle of this
project
so um
i don't need life insurance if i die
sharon has lots and lots and lots of
money and assets
so
however when we were building this
particular building the first building
on this campus we built three since then
but it was a huge project to us
uh hunt i mean it was tens of millions
of dollars
and sharon was afraid we get halfway
through this thing
and can't finish it
if i die
so during that period of time i took out
some life insurance make sure the
building got finished
so that she was not burdened with other
assets having to be liquidated to take
care of that
and so for a short period of time i
picked up like a five-year policy right
to do that so because we had a little
conversation here now we have a detailed
in-depth conversation every year because
it's complicated there's a lot of people
involved there's 200 employees there's
200 leaders there's ramsey family
there's a lot going there's a lot going
on so there's a lot of responsibility
that needs to be transferred so we
always have the if dave dies this year
meeting and it's always pleasant not at
all they could have named it a little
better well we could have named we we
should have named the monty python
meeting i'm feeling much better it's
just a flesh wound but um so but the uh
but you know you got to have these
discussions and you need you need to get
if you don't have a big
extensive estate it doesn't matter you
still need a will i mean you got two
french bulldogs and a wife and a paid
for house taken care of you need a will
yeah it's there's not a lot of
complication here but you need a will
and you need life insurance make sure
whitney's okay and
uh she needs life insurance make sure
you're okay
and at this early stage in your all's
lives and careers and so forth and so
you you put these things in place so
that the family doesn't feel the strain
of that 32 year old young man calling me
and he just lost his dad and yet he's
having to carry the weight
of this whole thing you could feel it on
top of grieving there's a whole mess you
feel the voice you're feeling this voice
do people think if they don't talk about
a will it will help their chances of
staying alive longer i have actually had
people tell me that i don't want to do a
will because i'll die there's a higher
chance of you dying if you like it
increases your probability of death when
you do a will oh
i mean it's like a superstition or
something yeah and yet we've done
detailed research everyone's going to
die i want to see that 100 percent
mortality rate
i mean other than jesus and elijah
there's a hundred percent mortality rate
in the nation there are exceptions in
the human race i mean it's just you're
not getting out of this alive so
um
uh the the you know
maybe a methuselah i mean we could throw
that one oh that's a good one too
there's a couple a couple of ascensions
but
short of that
short of that uh you're pretty much
gonna die so you need a will because
your name is not one of those names i
just listed so you're gonna die there's
someone named methuselah out there who
goes dave dave i'm telling you that
and whoever's parent that named them
that yeah they need to be smacked so and
this stuff doesn't take long people
think this is going to take me hours and
hours i mean you can jump onto our
website and get these things done mama
bear legal forms makes it really easy
and you need to do it and zander
insurance makes it as easy as it can
possibly be to get insurance and you
need to get insurance our life insurance
premium just came out of our bank
account and then you need to talk about
it so you talk to the four kids and go
hey mom
doesn't work and how we how here's what
you're going to do mom's going to work
by the way honey if i die this year we
got no money you're going to work
uh so you kind of got this thing it's
all laid instead of this this mythology
that everything's going to be perfect
and work out the way we planned in the
middle of this project halfway building
this project up on the farm while we're
living in a trailer
which is what they're doing
you know what's the plan well there
wasn't one
because when nobody assumed anybody's
gonna die
and so it leaves everybody in a mess
and uh oh and by the way when you get
the will done read the will to the
family tell everybody what it says this
is not a movie
where you go in and there's a surprise
and there's weird clauses in there and
there's a big fight you know there's all
you know the trophy
stepmother with the dysfunctional child
and
all these things those those are not
those people exist but that don't don't
do all of them don't do don't do a movie
script do a will
it makes for everybody and go listen
you're you're doing cocaine you're not
in the will okay just go ahead and tell
everybody that way you're not confused
well i i have my rights you don't have
any rights it's my money i'm not you
know any right you're a cocaine addict
you get nothing you know and just tell
people what their the heroin is a
problem or not you know the crack house
you're running down the street it's a
problem we're not leaving your money for
this
so just go ahead and say it out loud and
it's not a punishment thing it's we
don't want to finance your nuttiness
and we'll that's going to kill you and
and so you just go ahead and take care
of all that while you're alive if people
are gonna be pissed off go ahead and do
it while you're alive
and and and then there's less stress for
everybody left behind yeah way less and
following the baby because he's grieving
the loss of his grandparents his dad
and now feeling all this responsibility
and all these options are coming at him
like flaming arrows and he's 32 and he's
got to figure this out
that's just not fair
no so if you're listening to this
these baby steps are not just to set
yourself up it's to help your family
it's how you say i love you when you
leave them with no debt and you've got a
will and you've got life insurance
that allows them to actually grieve
instead of clean up a whole mess while
they're trying to grieve the loss of
someone they loved yeah it changes it
changes the chemistry of the whole
situation from combustible
to
chill and changes the legacy too yeah
yeah and and it's just
you know it's
run around trying to figure out how
we're going to pay for the funeral
because and yet there's money over there
in the checking account but we can't get
to it because we didn't have a will and
we've got to sell the property and the
truck got to get it the whole thing to
get a death certificate because there's
no will
yeah yeah it's just a um
so guys you know
78 of americans died without a will
that's just stupid
it's just
stupid it's not expensive and it doesn't
take a long time there's no excuse not
to have one i'm not picking on the
gentleman that passed away and his son
calling i'm not talking about that
that's but it's just for the rest of you
my gosh
love your family well
do be grown do grown-up stuff
you know take care of grown-up be it i
mean be an adult
you know act like you're like the digits
on your age indicate you should be
acting you know take care of business
and so one way my wife and my family and
my kids and my grandkids feel very loved
by papa davis i've got a detailed nerded
out complete
gone over every year thing that when i
die
um they're just gonna cheer and start
cashing the checks i mean it's going to
be awesome there we go celebrate
play some eagles eat some good food call
it some eagles crank up some foreign
here we go
[Laughter]
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
psalm 7714 you are the god who performs
miracles you display your power among
the peoples our scripture of the day
john rockefeller said good management
consists in showing average people how
to do the work of superior people
whoa yeah that's probably true we
probably are all our average people that
we learn to do superior work a little
snobbish there mr rockefeller but uh
it's okay i'm going with it i like it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
boise idaho is up next justin's on the
line hey justin how are you
hey davis it's jesse oh i'm sorry jesse
what's up
uh so i'm in a bit of a dilemma i uh
kind of
back and forth all week on what to do um
and i'm like dude i just i need some i
need some help um
i worked for a company for i moved my
family over there for two years uh i've
been here for two years i moved my
family over here to take a job
uh been doing this for 16 years the same
work the same job
eight of the 16 i've been running
my own crews and stuff um
so when they got here
the promises were made and then come to
find out they were lacking that anyway
so that's the truth i mean you just
drove by that i have no idea what you
just said
promises were made and what
so there were some promises made
if you come to work for us
um
you know
um then we'll give you this and this
um after a certain amount of time well
that was just to lure me in because they
were so short on guys it seems like
anyway
um so you no longer trust the integrity
of the people you work for
exactly i don't i don't know if i i
trust them oh no you just said you
didn't
i know right exactly okay okay so
i don't i don't trust them um
so i this winter
um
sometimes we get laid off due to weather
and stuff like that so we're laid off
for a year a month or so
and they ended up working a couple of
guys that were you know knew how you
guys that
uh
the way it works is that you you work
you start from the top and you work your
way down
to the
guys lower on the totem pole right
no i don't know what you're talking
about
well okay so like who do you what are
you working down to
most people work up the totem pole not
down right no i'm saying in the
wintertime
oh in terms of who you're firing
well laying off due to weather
you lay off the expensive guy you lay
off the expensive guys first okay i got
that
well you guys would like
lack of experience is usually
where they start um the newer guys
um
anyway so i went and jesse what's your
question well i want to get to downtown
okay i put in the resume
i got an offer from another company the
other company is willing to pay me
this for the same work
fifty two dollars an hour well i make
thirty dollars an hour right now
all the same thing
uh
well 401k is where i get to are you 401k
dude you don't need a 401k when you
double your income
okay you go get a roth ira screw it
you're going to double your income you
go from 30 to 52 that's almost double
i'm not staying anywhere for a 401k for
doubling your income is the other place
a good place to work
yes i went up checked them out drove
around with them
they they treat you right you know none
of those promises that can't be kept
they told me
this is what's going to happen this is
what you're going to get and this is
what do you do for a living
i um
i guess to sum it up if i was uh
build design engineer roads uh
you know all the stuff that you would
you know build roads basically okay it's
a road subdivision parking lots all the
underground stuff that goes into it
um are you a heavy equipment guy i just
yes okay all right cool and i've i have
like i said i have eight years running
running cruise yeah so when i came over
here they were like well yeah
you can run a crew here
we'll put you out you know
but oh hey wait a sec
we don't have enough guys so can would
you mind working with these guys for a
little bit longer
well
it seemed like it was just to lure me
here because they were so short on guys
they were desperate they needed guys
the the second company or the first
company
who's lowering you
so just leave the first company you got
a great offer what's stopping you at
this point
i would just want because i mean that
the first company there they i mean they
do like great 401k matches forget the
401k you hate it you don't trust them
and you're going to get paid almost
double
okay
so what do i do
um
so if i'm putting in like right now i'm
putting ten percent in my 401k and
they're matching it at six percent
i go to this new company how much do i
put into that you
roll your old 401k with a smartvestor
pro to a traditional and you open two
roth iras one for you and one for your
wife
if you're married but dude regardless
you can just save money mutual funds if
you have to if you don't have once you
maxed out your roth iras but retirement
plan is not what the problem here is
retirement plan is a two on a scale of
one to ten no integrity is a ten on the
scale of one to ten doubling your income
is a ten on a scale of 1 to 10. this is
what's known as a no-brainer
take the new job quit the old job leave
no-brainer you'll work out the
investment stuff later
okay
but you don't stay at a company making
half the money that you don't trust
because they have a 401k
no
not even close
so that that's the deal right there
i think i lost brain calories on that
one dave that was a lot for me that was
hard i was trying to track man well it
was it was circular we got there but we
got there
jarik is with us in texas hi rick how
are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so
uh i'm a college student freshman by
year sophomore by hour
here at west texas a m
university in canyon and i actually took
your
i took your finance course my senior
year for money matters
and i had some questions about saving
you know i have some money saved up just
from work
graduation presents scholarship refunds
that kind of thing
and you know i just don't want to put
that kind of thing in the brick and
mortar bank you know it doesn't make
nothing so i've been looking maybe like
a high yield savings kind of thing
something with high liquidity so i can
take it out if i pay for something no
you notice what high yield was right
you know what high yield was right you
look at the percentage on the high yield
yes sir it's only 0.5 yeah i know it's
not exactly high yield it's kind of an
oxymoron well compared to the other 3.25
versus a 0.5
i mean it's it's the whole thing's
irrelevant it's just a parking spot for
your money
that that you're not going to lose it
you're not going to invest it because
you need it for college you don't need
it right now but you're going to need it
later so you're just going to park it
somewhere if you want to park it in high
yield that's not really high then that's
okay if you want to put in a money
market that's okay none of it's going to
earn over one right now how much money
are we talking
uh
some
four to six thousand yeah just park it
you're going to get pennies on it either
just park it i mean you can put in a
shoe box it's not much different but i
mean just park it because you're going
to need it later keep your hands off of
it
when you have a semester where some
where there's a little bit of a gap in
there and you've got to do some fill-in
you're going to need that four to six
and it'll help you graduate college
completely debt-free as you push your
way on through but you just need a
parking lot a parking spot
for your money and you're not having to
pay for it they're going to pay you a
tiny bit to park your car there that's
all it is just park it in the parking
spot and get back to it later and you've
done a really good job setting your life
up here very very very well done tariq
very good job you've got your whole life
to invest so don't worry about that
right now we want you to get through
college debt free get your emergency one
in place get a great job and then we
have 20 30 years to invest you're gonna
be just fine yeah you don't need to
worry about investing right now you're
the investment get through school debt
free
well done george good hour fun times
thank you good job to the booth people
well done both people both folk it's all
good in there
and uh all of you there were 17 people
in there earlier so i'm not naming them
all
you can't even call the role they don't
even know my children's names let's put
the uh let's put that hour in the books
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramsaysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
you